[Music]
rejection you saw us
I'm John new so that's gone Jordan peels
gonna follow film yes I completely got
the whole film right on the first try
first shot they didn't have to look
anything up easy viewing experience yeah
man he was dead the whole time it's
crazy he's crazy just stolen right out
of John Carpenter's Sixth Sense yeah we
saw the movie us last night packed house
opening night what an experience we're
gonna go into that in a second I wanted
to did something off the table really
quick we would like to do a spoiler
review for this movie we really would
like to do a spoiler talk for it the
thing though is both John and I feel
like we would most certainly need a
second viewing at least not because like
we just want to make sure we get
everything you know right to clear
detail it's just this is one of those
films that undoubtably
you would probably get a million things
more from it it's the kind of film that
by the time it ends you would have a
completely different viewing experience
it's not you just get it more you would
just have a completely different viewing
which is awesome that's just an awesome
thing I will feel like I've truly seen
this movie once I've seen it twice
that's it yeah those it's kind of hard
to explain in the sense of the like why
you need a second viewing for it until
you see it then you would go oh I get
why now that doesn't minimize the effect
of a first viewing experience per se the
thing though is we don't have time to
watch it a second time on the weekend
not just not really no some maybe we'll
do it we have screening set up for other
movies on both Monday and Tuesday to
attend we're at an event all day
Saturday for our own mental health we've
had to make a rule where Sunday's we
take off and we just really want to
stick by that so what we can do is talk
about our non-spoiler reaction to the
movie the first time around
impressions yeah I feel like for anyone
who watches this movie if you're gonna
do a review of your first
I'm watching it in a review of your
second time watching it there would be
very different reviews really that'd be
like way for anyone and I hope if you
haven't seen the movie this kind of
entices you to watch it a little bit
more when I was on the John Campea show
there was a point where he was talking
about the Rotten Tomatoes reviews that
had come out early and there's this this
vibe and impression I got that it would
be one of those films with were they
were like Jordan Peele you're free to do
whatever you want and I had an
impression that it might be like a
critical darling but it might be very
divisive amongst audiences and then sure
enough by the time the movie was over I
was like now I'm even more confident
than that theory that this will be a
divisive amongst audiences first person
we spoke to upon leave exiting the
theater was not part of our group was
came up to us yeah yeah he could tell we
were saw the same movie was like what
you guys think and then the second we
started to give our answer he was like
ah so this is gonna garner a lot of
different responses and I think it's
gonna be one of those movies that tests
your sensibility whether you want a
solid answer the second you leave the
theater or whether you like to sit with
and think about a movie
yeah like decode cuz that's a film in
this right now on Rotten Tomatoes that
I'm guessing that this will land in the
audience score between 60 to 65% that's
where I'm guessing it'll land right now
on Tiburon tomatoes this is Friday we're
filming at 94% critic score 72% audience
score could be different by the time
this video is uploaded either way our
impression of the film I really admire
this movie I really respect this movie a
hell of a lot yeah it's certainly
ambitious it's very weird the trailer
isn't misleading I'm thinking it's not
gonna be here it's a very strange film I
did leave going I'm excited to see what
creative input he has on the twilight
zone because this does have a lot of
like vibes sort of like that to my light
zone esque I feel like the one
connective tissue that you can solidly
draw between get out in this movie is
the fact that they have this kind of
curious weird dready center that does
feel crack while it's on it has like not
a plot twist specifically but there's
just a twist to the tone yeah it feels
Twilight Zone II yeah yeah I'll say it's
just like with if you're walking in for
like a horror suspenseful movie I think
it's a really great one at that like I
think it's just a straightforward horror
suspense film
wonderful I think that would get out
there very different movies varied it's
actually really hard to talk about this
movie without spoiling it while they
both have social commentary I feel like
get out social commentary was very
specifically linked to race and then
here well there's you know elements of
that here it's not exactly the main
thing for sure about no it's about a
whole bunch of other things a lot of its
open to interpretation I did not fully
get it by the time the movie was done no
I did not
some people have been like others it's
John exposition dump it could have left
some stuff ambiguous I'm like huh you
know I I don't think on a first viewing
you would just I just don't believe you
can fully get everything this movie is
talking about everything that's going on
this time there's so much symbolism as
far as a directors movie the writing and
this is really good but I think Jordan
Peele took it to a whole other level in
terms of directing craftsmanship working
with his DP on the film working with his
music composer on this movie he took it
to a whole other degree in this film
that blew my mind honestly yeah I think
there's something that's very much worth
respecting regardless of how you feel
about the ultimate like outcome of the
movie is the direction because you know
like people used to always laugh in film
school and scoff a little bit when we
would go over scenes be like what's the
meaning of this shot and and people
would be like there's not necessarily a
meaning to every shot but at the same
time there are some movies you watch
where you're like the set dressing the
color choices little mannerisms and the
performances like it feels very authored
and crafted and of Jordan peels voice
yeah and it carries again from you can
see that level of detail and
craftsmanship and sense for subtleties
and and symbolism coming out of get out
into this but this is so much more
there's some reveals that are very easy
to understand by the end of this movies
like very easy to understand so I'm not
even call predictable for a lot of this
there's probably so much meaning in
layers to almost every frame in this
movie yeah that you just don't pick up
on the first time and for a movie that
has so much riding on coincidences and
like little eerie details little ends
there off with people you know you're
not gonna catch everything up front and
also what I noticed is that this move
the way at least the dialogue is handled
in the character stuff is handled you
can catch everything but not everything
is very on the nose so you do got to pay
attention and there's certain things
that you might miss the main big reveals
of the movie communicating what to sort
of try to understand in terms of its its
messages or commentary the reveals all
usually happened in the last third of
the movie like how most movies do I
don't really feel like that's a spoiler
I feel like I've heard some non-spoiler
review does that actually say more
things that are more spoiler fail then
what we just said right yeah like things
are like you shouldn't have said that in
your review you know lines boilers are
gonna be yeah I loved the first
two-thirds of this movie so much even
when you're confused because that's the
point you're in these character shoes
you're supposed to be confused it's home
invasion with this weird doppelganger
twist where the people who are invading
your home are people who look exactly
like your family yeah
and they're terrorizing you [ __ ] just
gets way crazier way weirder violence
stuff starts to unfold some like it's
more violent than than I think get out
and it's funnier than get out I love the
humor in this movie I feel like some
people might find it a little bit out of
place at times for me I liked when it
was kind of jarring I liked when it was
unexpected they handled it in a way that
was like I don't know what I would do in
this situation yeah I wanted to say
something you know it feels intentional
even with some music moments that they
do with comedy I've really admired the
choices of when to put into humor there
are some very intense moments throughout
the film so even in the first two-thirds
before like you start getting answers
and start getting like real real clear
explanations on some stuff that's going
on and why as well as really surreal
secrets as well because you're supposed
to be at that point going I'm confused
but there's enough to latch on to and
grasp on to the immediacy of the
situation where it's very thrilling very
gripping and I think I think where some
people are falling off with this movie
is by the time you start getting reveals
I'm noticing a weird reaction to the
reveals some people are saying too much
of an exposition and then some people
are going I don't [ __ ] get it you
know I'm like wait a minute
which one is it
comes down to sensibility yeah the
exposition dump itself is plot based
it's not based in the symbolism and the
deeper meanings of the movie and the
movie leaves you with those things
yeah code on your own I feel like that's
where a lot of people are kind of
falling off with this movie and you know
I don't fully get it I'm sure I'll get
it more on a second viewing I'm sure
I'll Google some [ __ ] if like find out
the deeper meanings and I bet that even
googling trying to find out what the
deeper meanings aren't all these
articles that people are putting out or
you know taking what Jordan Peele is
saying that he wanted a comment on or
talked about here there there's
definitely things here that are left
solely to the viewers interpretation
there's their elements here that you
might not get that you could probably
look up and then go okay that makes more
sense but then there's other elements
that are left open to interpretation and
then there are some things though that I
feel are clearly left to not be fully
explained there are certain things that
even when I was looking up going wait a
minute but but why and how yeah I don't
feel are fully meant to be fully
explained in this movie I feel like
that's part of the intent with it
because sometimes when I look back on
some of the reveals then I look back
though I feel like on a second I might
get it more but even in retrospect I'm
like wait a minute but this this kind of
doesn't make sense to me and I kind of
would have want a little bit explanation
here you know yeah sure I mean and
that's another thing where I'm gonna
have a more solid opinion about it once
I've seen it again cuz yeah I walked out
with a fair amount of like questions
things eating at my mind and not enough
of the movie to really solve all those
problems in my head I really appreciate
what has happened here it's gonna take
me a little while to figure out how I
feel about it
you know there's just so much here of
quality and I think it's one of those
movies that I love the movie yeah I do
like hey you know I've talked with a few
people who are like whatever about it
for me this is a cool viewing experience
oh yeah I'm like it's not one of those
movies that you know sucks the first
time and you're watching it's good the
second time it's one of those films that
is is intended to be rewatched some
people find that to be a hindrance for a
film I don't I don't find that to be an
issue if if a movie is meant for a
rewatch it's so nuanced and so detailed
and there's no one thing a movie ought
to be yeah
we haven't talked about the caste in
this video yeah yeah but the caste is
phenomenal in the film like that's what
I mean it's just the first two-thirds
it's just a pure horror suspenseful
movie with comedy infused it's wonderful
I feel like people drop off in the third
a little bit because that's when you're
supposed to be like clear-cut on
everything but I think in the first 2/3
with the directing I'll cover the music
the casting or Lupita Nyong'o playing to
different people and here phenomenal man
she better to get an Oscar nom I don't
care what other performances go out this
year she better get an Oscar nomination
yeah Winston Duke in this film who has a
lot of the comedic relief in tension
he's not a comedic relief character I'd
say but a lot of the relief human a lot
of the relieving moments come through
his character I'd say and he's not the
type of character you might expect him
to be like I've heard a lot of different
responses to this character some people
appreciate the way that they don't
portray him as this like overly tough
always in control kind of guy I know
some people kind of think he's a bit of
a punk and yeah I liked what he brought
to this a whole lot although they felt
like a real fan they feel like a real
family like everything the whole family
is good at no one's really talking about
the kids in the movie I agree - yeah the
kids are great especially the daughter
in the movie I thought she was a hottie
right Joseph I thought she was
incredible in this movie like really
good and the kit of the son Evan Alex
was also really good yes the star
performers in this movie are Lupita
Nyong'o and Winston Duke for sure but
the but even the kids and then there's
other characters in here they're teased
in the trailer like Elisabeth Moss and
di Deker I'm a little bit more
questionable about the writing of the
way those characters were handled
honestly they're a bit more caricatures
and we spend way less time with them
yeah but even with the moments you get
with them and it's like yeah I can't go
into it but I'm a little I'm kind of
good that's where I'm questionable about
those per say the writing about it not
not so much the meaning so yeah I think
it's just a suspenseful horror movie
with comedy infused I think it's great
and the more I think about it the more I
love it I you know to compare this to
get out is not necessary because they're
so different the thing is I don't feel
like a lot of people expected this
experience I feel like we did to leave
in this state yeah yeah
hey I did so I'm not mad about it I'm
not mad that I don't quite understand
all of it because it's one of those
movies that you see where and everyone
will have a different response to this
but I feel like even the things I don't
understand were placed there with intent
there are movies you see that you walk
out not understanding you're like I
think they just didn't think about this
and that's kind of lazy yeah it sounds
like a plot hole yeah there's stuff that
might not at first makes sense but I
just I got imagine that there's just
more to it than I have seen from this
first viewing yeah yeah yeah and so
because of that and because I just love
this kind of movie in general and I am
happy that we're potentially gonna get
more of them I like things that force me
to go out and think a little about them
and that are challenging and that leave
me with a weird feeling afterwards you
know yeah cuz I think the one compares
I'll make in terms of viewing experience
with get out versus this is get out had
a very immediate plot that you can
easily understand and then it has its
symbolism and meaning you could latch on
to when you're watching it and then get
more from it than the second time
whereas with this movie if you don't get
the symbolism and meaning it can kind of
take you out of it a little bit in terms
of fully grasping and how do I really
feel about this movie do you know what I
mean by that yeah I was feeling like you
missed some it's like we get out you can
kind of just take away the plot and and
take away the situation everything and
maybe not even digest the meaning and
still love it whereas here if you don't
digest any of the meaning or symbolism
you might be like what I don't get it
get out gets out there throughout a lot
of the movie I feel like that movies
confusion can be solved by oh no this is
what they were doing and here's how that
works and it's kind of easy to explain
once you understand it whereas this
movie I think is also just trying to do
a lot more things and touch on a lot
more ideas so there isn't just one thing
to understand about it part of the fun
too is you know a divisive movie there's
lots to talk about what audiences have
to say about this and I can't wait for
all the countless YouTube videos that
come out with this movie about the
meeting and symbolism and the hit you
know that's they're already puffing
they're already popping up and we're
gonna get we're just gonna keep getting
more of them so I feel like it's an
exciting film to have right now actually
when I wanted anything less yeah
yeah I don't think I would have wanted
something that was crisp and easy to
understand you know alright guys well
did you see us
did you like us comment below subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell and we'll catch you
guys soon